today on the Matt Walsh show we are told
that we should defund the police because
black lives matter black lives matter so
we had it up on the police because the
police are killing so many black people
that's the claim anyway but I've got a
better defunding campaign that is sure
to save many more black lives and I will
propose it today also 5 headlines
including the media's expected pivot
back to coronavirus fear-mongering so
they they have forgotten about it for
the last two weeks because they want to
support the the riots and the protests
but now they're going right back to
telling us we're all going to die if we
gather together in large groups because
of the coronavirus we knew this was
gonna happen
but it doesn't make it any less
ridiculous we'll talk about that and in
our daily cancellation I cancel House
Democrats for the most outrageous bit of
pandering we have ever seen I think from
politicians all of that coming up but I
want to mention right at the top here
that today is my 500th episode somehow
and for some reason I have done 500 of
these things so I want to thank you all
for supporting the show all this time
unless you have not supported it all
this time if you just started watching
now then please get the hell out of here
you bandwagon jumper we don't need you
actually we do need you I apologize
please stay please forgive me now in
celebration of this momentous occasion I
wanted to do something very special
something I've never done before
something to signify the enormity of
this event and so I have decided to
throw some confetti but I didn't have
confetti so instead I just tore up some
pieces of used napkin and I will now to
commemorate this event in an act of
boisterous celebration I will toss this
confetti joyfully into the air here we
go
you
well that was pretty that was pretty
significant and pretty exciting anyway
so there's that let's let's move on let
me take a second here and tell you about
our our sponsors at ready wise you know
our sponsor wise company recently
changed their name to ready wise and now
is a great time to tell you about them
because it's obviously a better time
than any to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options you know
because you never know you never know
what's going to happen and it's really
important to be prepared in an emergency
this is something that maybe I haven't
been the best at but now with ready wise
I know at least I've got the food
squared away and ready to go ready Wise
has many options like emergency meals
they've got freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition they've got new adventure
meals for hiking camping and other
outdoor activity so this isn't just you
know you've got the the meals and
emergency you've also got him for
convenience if you're going out hiking
or something you want to bring ready
wise meals with you they're easy to
prepared you just add water you have a
very light very very long shelf life as
well ready wise makes being prepared
simple and affordable you can order
online and have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep it's as easy
as that
very affordable as well ready wise uses
the finest ingredients and latest food
preparation technology to ensure optimal
taste and freshness so just because it's
convenient just because it's something
you're stashing for an emergency doesn't
mean you have to give up on taste you
never want to do that with food this
week my listeners can get free shipping
at ready wise calm when entering Walsh
at checkout or by calling eight five
five four seven five three o eight nine
ready Wise has a 90 day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that's
ready wise Rea dy WI sce.com promo code
Walsh to get free shipping today there
there are two slogans that we've heard
quite a bit in recent weeks one is
one is black lives matter the other is
defund the police so we need to define
the police because and and of course
from the perspective of the activists
they're going to connect those two and
say we should define the police because
black lives matter if we want to protect
black lives we must we have to define
something and what should we defined the
police okay that's the logic now there
are many problems with the idea of
defunding the police we talked about
some of those problems yesterday though
I suspect it's probably not necessary to
go into detail explaining why we can't
get rid of police departments any
reasonable person can off the top of
their head come up with ten reasons at
least why that's a bad idea and then
they could give you another ten because
it's really quite obvious so instead
what I what I'd like to explore is this
idea of defunding something for the sake
of protecting black lives since they
since the left has brought up the
subject I okay well they brought it up
so let's talk about it and I've got a
better idea I've got a defunding plan
that would directly and immediately save
many black lives and that would be of
course Planned Parenthood we could
defunded Planned Parenthood better get
after defunding Planned Parenthood let's
abolish abortion entirely yeah that
should be the next step if black lives
matter and they do then certainly all of
the many millions of children black
children murdered in abortion clinics
every year matter don't they I mean they
either matter or they don't a thing
either matters or it doesn't if if those
children don't matter then black lives
don't matter if a life doesn't matter at
its earliest and most vulnerable stage
then it doesn't inherently matter at all
inherent okay that means belonging to a
thing by its nature so if black life if
any human life at all black white or
otherwise inherently matters if it has
inherent value that is value belonging
to it by its nature then it has that
value and it matters
from the moment of its conception from
the moment of its existence if something
has any inherent value of any kind any
inherent quality of any kind it must
have that quality from the beginning
otherwise it's not inherent otherwise
its value or it's a quality that it that
it it's gained or achieved at some other
point which means it is not inherent now
this is in xscape Abul you know you
really can't get around it if that life
does not inherently matter at that stage
then it does not have inherent value at
all and therefore its value is based on
something else on its usefulness to
society on its on its desirability to
others on its ability to care for itself
whatever it is whatever the value is
based on the value is then conditional
so the real question is when someone
says black lives matter
I guess the follow-up question we should
ask is are you saying the black life
matters conditionally or are you saying
that it matters inherently does it
matter by its nature does or does it
matter because of because of something
else a black person matter the black
person's life matters is it because of
the the the things that that person can
do for us how desirable that person is
or is there is there something deeper
now
I would suspect that the people who go
around saying black lives matter they
mean it inherently they mean it on the
deeper level I would suspect that if you
tried to attach the word conditionally
to the phrase black life matters
everybody who says black lives matter
would be very upset about that and would
accuse you of being racist I'm going to
assume that I could be wrong now the
people in BLM if they want to come out
and say I don't know we mean it
conditionally blmc black lives matter
conditionally if that's what you mean to
say then then tell us but I'm going to
assume you don't mean that
of course if
is what you mean then it's then that
rather weakens the slogan doesn't it now
here's here's the answer that I give
anyway I guess I really can't speak for
anybody else but I say that black life
matters inherently I say that all human
life matters inherently which means
those millions of black lives killed by
abortion are victims deserving of at
least the same level of outrage that
we've shown for George Floyd probably
quite a bit more outrage in fact because
these are these are innocent lives
who've never had the chance to do
anything to live to make choices they've
been deprived of all of that and there
are a lot of these victims by the way a
lot according to a study published on
the NIH website the black abortion rate
is three times higher than the white
abortion er at least three times higher
I have read numbers putting it four or
five times higher the CDC tells us that
over thirty five percent of abortions
are performed on black women though
black women only comprise less than
fifteen percent of all women of
childbearing age in the country so 15
percent accounting for 35 percent
how many black babies have been killed
since roe v wade well we don't have an
exact number those are not numbers that
the abortion industry is necessarily
eager to keep track of and advertise but
if you look at the percentages and you
look at the rate and you look at the
overall number of abortions we can say
confidently that tens of millions tens
of millions of black babies have been
killed since roe v-- wade the black
population is significantly smaller than
it otherwise would have been if not for
this carnage and it gets worse in some
cities like New York City for example
more black babies are aborted than born
if you're a black child conceived in New
York City it is more likely that you
will be killed in the womb then
delivered into the world alive and
breathing again you cannot get around
this you cannot coherent ly argue that
any life matters black or otherwise
effusive
or the mass slaughter of that life in
the womb or at any other point of
development and now a message from
LifeLock it's important message to
because we've all been in the situation
where we get duped by an Internet
scammer or at least almost duped because
these scams are getting they're getting
more clever ok it's not just about the
Nigerian Prince's these days
they're getting very clever and how they
obtain your information the April 15th
tax deadline was pushed off until July
15th and of course we're all relieved by
this but the extension also gives
additional time for fraudsters to mine
for data to sell so proactive approaches
to protection are more important than
ever
after all the Government Accountability
Office found that fraudsters use false
identities to steal at least one point
six eight billion dollars in tax refunds
in 2016 you don't want to be someone who
falls victim to that every day we put
our information at risk on the internet
and cyber criminals around the world
keep finding new ways to steal
identities they're getting more creative
with it LifeLock then is a leader in
identity theft protection and they're
staying one step ahead of the bad guys
every step of the way if you become a
victim of identity theft LifeLock can
help you restore your identity easier
than you would be able to do on your own
life lock detects a wide range of
identity theft threats like your social
security number being up for sale on the
dark web that's the kind of thing that
probably the average person isn't gonna
be able to find out on their own nobody
can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses LifeLock can see threats that
you might miss on your own join now and
save up to 25% off your first year go to
life lock calm slash Walsh
that's like flock dot-com slash walls
for 25% off now let's say that 20
million black babies have been killed by
abortion since roe v-- wade it's you
know it's probably considerably more
than that but let's let's go with a
conservative estimate and say 20 million
now I want you to actually picture that
because because this is one disadvantage
one of many that the victims of abortion
face that their slaughter is off-camera
it is shielded from our eyes it happens
in in a building in an on
script you know sort of an oculus
looking building in a shopping mall many
times it's not on video and these these
children are not shouting I can't
breathe if they're crying we can't hear
them and so we don't picture it we can't
we don't have any real image of it but
let's try for a minute let's as
disturbing as it is picture in your head
twenty million victims picture 20
million dead babies 20 million you know
in a mass grave okay now look at that
carnage look at that bloodbath and tell
me that you can give it a thumbs up
while still claiming that life matters
tell me that you can look at that mass
grave with 20 million dead black babies
and and and and and still say that you
believe that black life matters it's
absurd it is a gross morbid absurdity to
make that claim while supporting that
you know this is not this is not some
cheap
what about ISM game this is me listening
to someone and taking them at their word
you say that black life matters you say
you believe that I believe it you say
you believe okay well great because if
you believe that then I would like to
call your attention to that tens of
millions of black babies being killed in
abortion clinics mancine like a logical
thing to bring into this discussion it
seems like if we ignore that then the
whole discussion is ridiculous do you
know how many unarmed black men were
were killed by police last year nine
nine and not all of them unjustly by the
way just because an unarmed person and
there were more than twice as many white
people killed
unarmed people killed by police last
year now not all of them unjustly when
you hear an armed person killed by
police that doesn't mean that it wasn't
in self-defense on part on the part of
the police officer take the Michael
Brown situation to forensics
investigations including Obama's DOJ
looked into that investigated it and
found that he was justified Michael
Brown was attacking the police officer
trying to take his gun and kill him
forensics evidence eyewitness evidence
once all the smoke cleared all of the
you know in the false reporting and the
in the false narratives and everything
once all that was was cleared out of the
way and we were left with the evidence
and the actual eyewitnesses it turned
out that Michael Brown was trying to
kill this man and was shot for his
trouble that is a totally justified
killing entirely the fault of Michael
Brown he brought that on himself is it
is it a terrible tragedy yes the tragedy
anytime someone throws their life away
okay someone got someone you know an
armed robber goes into a convenience
store appoints his gun gets shot by the
store clerk and dies that's a tragedy in
a certain sense it's it's not an
injustice it's not an outrage the store
clerk was was acting in self-defense but
it's a tragedy that a person is throwing
their life away for no reason throwing
the life away for you know fifty seven
dollars in the cash register
Michael Brown threw his life away that's
a tragic terrible thing but in any case
that's an example of how an unarmed
killing can be completely justified so
but let's nine unarmed black people
killed by police last year nine compare
that to twenty million I mean
we are focusing talking about black
lives matter focusing the conversation
entirely around a comparative few black
people unjustly killed by police and
meanwhile we've got millions millions of
victims and we're ignoring them how can
we do that and I even hear from pro-life
or sometimes to say oh you know don't
don't bring this isn't it's not
appropriate to bring this up right now
what we're talking about black lives
matter and everyone's talking about a
few you know a few over here we got a we
got millions of victims over here how
can we not bring that up it's insane not
to bring it up so this is really the
balls in your court your BLM activists
you're someone on the left balls in your
court here you have to make up your mind
you have to make a decision does a black
life matter inherently or not is it
inherent or is it conditional that's the
question you have to answer and you see
I know what your answer is though it's
the answer you don't want to give your
answer is conditional that's the answer
you give for all human life black white
any race what you believe is that that
value of that life is conditional and so
a child in the womb the the condition by
which that child's life matters is is if
the mother wants that baby if the mother
doesn't want the baby then the life
doesn't matter at all it's garbage
literally throw it in the dumpster which
is what they do with these babies I
throw it on medical waste they throw the
bodies in a medical waste dumpster so
you are someone who believes in in the
conditional value of human life but you
won't say that because you recognize
that it's horrific is a horrific
nihilistic point of view that that
if you're honest about it renders you
incapable actually of really speaking
out against any injustice because
according to your view no life actually
really matters it doesn't actually
matter doesn't really matter in certain
conditions we can sort of pretend that
it matters but it doesn't really doesn't
actually that's your view but you don't
want to say it and all I would suggest
is that if you have a view that you
don't want to say out loud because it's
so horrific aliy awful and if you have a
view that could logically be applied to
justify any injustice from the Holocaust
to slavery to anything else which the
belief in the conditional value of human
life does justify anything really
anything at all and and all of the
perpetrators of all the historic and
justices have believed in the
conditional value of human life and
that's the justification they gave for
what they were doing so if you hold a
belief like that that could be a really
good indication that your belief is
wrong and you need to change it and the
great thing is if you change this belief
in the conditional value of human life
and instead embrace the inherent value
of human life you don't have to
abandoned everything you're saying right
now about black lives matter quite the
contrary
now you can take it and it really means
something and you can apply it
consistently and you can speak out in
favor of not just the few black people
who are unjustly killed by police every
year but speak out in favor also of the
millions of children who have been
unjustly killed in abortion clinics
alright let's go to your news headlines
number one the looter err and all-around
scumbag who shot retired police captain
David Dorn was arrested this week his
name is a Stephan cannon but it won't
surprise you to learn that this is not
canons first run-in with the law in fact
in 2014 he was convicted of felony
robbery you
supposed to go to jail for seven years
guess how many days in jail he actually
served in prison that is zero so he's he
was accused convicted of arm of uh I
should say felony robberies convicted of
felony robbery supposed to go to jail
for seven years
spent zero days in prison he's given
probation he violated probation twice
avoided prison on both of those
occasions as well
now if cannon had actually served the
sentence and done the time that he was
supposed to do for the crime he had
committed he'd still be there right now
he wouldn't be getting out until what
2021 and David Doran would still be
alive now I don't know about you but
that's a trade that I would love to make
have this scumbag in jail out of the way
and still have David Dorn alive Dorn who
was a good man by all accounts an
accomplished man a man who cared about
his community clearly cared about
community went out in the middle of all
this chaos to try to stop people from
looting we could still have him
if this scumbag had been locked away
like he deserves I do have to wonder
though you know white privilege is that
what this is Stephan cannon a black man
committed felony robbery didn't spend a
day in prison how does that work with
the white privilege systemic racism
theory I'm just wondering how do you fit
that in how do you fit it in with black
lives matter considering the light
treatment that led directly to the death
of David dort was also a blackness these
are all questions that there's even more
questions that the BLM folks are gonna
have to answer number two all of the
brands you know have been jumping in
honoring George Floyd in black lives
matter wanting to make sure that
everybody knows how woke they are how
virtuous they are this one I thought was
pretty inspiring here's um gushers you
better remember them from those those
gross fruit snacks from the 1990s like
the fruit snacks that are filled in with
with this fruity mucus it's like if a
strawberry sneezed into a little plastic
bag and gave it to you to eat anyway
gushers came out and this is what they
had to say this says gushers wouldn't be
gushers without the black community and
your voices gushers wouldn't be gushers
without the black community what does
that even mean I don't know what that
means we're working with
fruit by the foot on creating space to
amplify that we see you we stand with
you so your fruit snack see you and
stand with you that's great
thank God you know this is what we need
we need gushers teaming up with fruit by
the foot maybe throw in dunkaroos teddy
grahams together all of the 90 snacks
will heal this nation I have confidence
hopefully a Tang can get in on the
action if you remember Tang I don't know
if they sell it anymore but for some
reason in the 90s we went through a fit
of psychosis briefly where everybody was
drinking Tang which is stuff that like
astronauts drink because they have to
cuz they're out in space and they have
nothing better and there was this phase
where we would drink it on purpose even
though there were other options number 3
well we knew this was gonna happen
it was inevitable despite cheering on
mass protests for the past two weeks and
completely putting the coronavirus to
the side and the process we knew that
once the protests in riots were over the
media would go right back to
fear-mongering about the virus again
pretending that the last two weeks never
happened and yet and yes here we are
here's the article from NPR it says
Trump to restart political rallies this
month despite coronavirus pandemic and
then it goes on to talk about you know
he's gonna be doing political rallies
and and that's so dangerous and says the
Trump campaign did not comment on the
specifics of safety protocols including
whether masks and temperature checks
would be mandated for entry but was any
of that mandated for the BLM rallies
temperature checks were they doing that
these people really have no shame no
shame at all and that is their greatest
advantage that's what we have to
understand that that these people in the
media they will lie and contradict
themselves without hesitation without
guilt without shame without worrying
about how stupid and and crazy and
dishonest they look to other people it's
almost like a superpower I almost envy
it because I still you know I still have
at least a semblance of a human
conscience in in my head and so
um it's it's always getting in the way
and you know you probably have this
experience too well you have a
conscience and it may not be the
greatest conscience in the world but you
have one and it tends to get in the way
it bothers you prevents you from being a
total lying piece of crap at all hours
of the day but a lot of the people the
media they don't have that obstacle to
navigate it really frees them up so just
do whatever they want that's the magical
thing about it number four there's a
reboot of Looney Tunes called Looney
Tunes cartoons very creative title but
we're told there's one major change
there's not gonna be any guns Elmer Fudd
will not have his iconic hunting rifle
the other guy who was the other one
two cans Sam that's the that's the
cartoon you seventy Sam he's not gonna
have his pistols I think two cans Sam
with pistols would be it would be
interesting but so there's not gonna be
any guns now this is dumb for all the
obvious reasons not the least of which
being that nobody as far as I'm aware
has ever been shot in Looney Tunes
related violence at least not in reality
but the other reason is that there's a
ton of violence in Looney Tunes if you
want to call it violence and apparently
what we're being told is that all of
that stuff is still gonna be a part of
the show so like you know TNT people
getting explode up anvils falling on
heads
apparently Elmer Fudd's gonna have a
scythe now instead of a gun they get
they gave him a creepier weapon now he's
running around with a with a with a
blade trying to stab Bugs Bunny so all
of that still allowed you could you're
gonna see characters getting crushed
with anvils which is a much more
gruesome and painful death than getting
shot I would think although I've never
been killed either way all of that's
fine but yeah you can't have you can't
have the guns okay five finally CNBC
reports coronavirus patients without
symptoms aren't driving the spread of
the virus according to the World Health
Organization some people particularly
young and otherwise healthy individuals
who are infected by the carnivores never
develop symptoms or only develop miles
and others might not develop symptoms
until they
after they were actually infected and
now that who is saying that those people
actually maybe can spread it but really
don't it's very rare that they spread it
now this is interesting because the
threat of asymptomatic carriers
spreading it I mean you you heard this
for three months just like I did this is
one of the main reasons why they shut
down society they put 40 million people
out of work they shut down the schools
and everything else one of the main
reasons they they're probably the number
one justification we were given is that
you've got a symptomatic people out
there spreading the virus like wildfire
turns out wasn't happening isn't
happening
won't happen really not much of a risk
okay hey no big deal right when they
shut down Society for no reason put 40
million people out of work for no reason
took kids out of school for no reason no
big deal hey mistakes happen
you're bad we get it not gonna hold it
against you of course you're not gonna
be held accountable no one's gonna be
held accountable for any of this we know
that are we gonna get to your daily
cancellation but before we do you know
there's so much that's been going on
this year that it's hard to even keep
track of everything it's like every
single every every week we've got
another crisis another huge news story
and then of course you have the
left-wing media constantly pushing their
agenda
remember those those consciousness
scumbags we were talking about before
and they're doing that instead of
actually reporting the news so it's very
hard to get the real story to sift
through all the garbage and get to the
truth and that's why you need a readers
pass today from daily wired.com you'll
get access to exclusive op-eds from us
your podcast host as well as guest
writers in depth analysis from all of
our daily wire reporters on top of our
regular breaking news everything
everything that that you know all of
this great information you get this
membership tier is already a bargain at
three dollars a month but if you join
today you get your first month for 99
cents you also get access to our mobile
app and receive push notifications for
breaking news and special content as
well as you can join the community of
daily wire members who are actively
commenting and discussing on our content
with each other
get all of that that's mobile ad free
access to all the daily wire news
exclusive op-eds even more on our mobile
app all for the low price of one dollar
actually less a penny less than one
dollar and best of all your dollars are
getting you the news you need without
the left to spin so head over to Delhi
wire.com slash subscribe and join today
okay for our daily cancellation we're
gonna be canceling House Democrats now I
essentially cancel Democrats every day
on this show implicitly but now we're
gonna have to make it explicit in this
case because of this
and there you see Democrats kneeling in
silence while wearing African garb in
honor of George Floyd this is pandering
on steroids this is pandering on
steroids with a shot of adrenaline after
chugging Red Bull all day this is if
somebody asked me what pandering is I
would show them this video it's it is
that that is what it is right there
though
I hang on a second is I can't let this
go go back and play I think it was like
two seconds to eight seconds to two
eight if we could play that and you see
that woman right there I don't know who
that is
she's trying to read her phone she's
tried to read her phone surreptitiously
like while kneeling she's got it under
her knees she's trying to read it I've
pulled this move many times in church
but I only just check football scores
that's the only time I would ever do it
okay I want to be clear about that and
that that is biblical I'm pretty sure
the Bible gives you permission to do
that except this woman has a millions of
cameras trained on her literally
millions probably and yet she thinks she
can get away with this and really I
guess she can get away because she's
masked this is one of the problems with
the masks is that you've got people you
know bandits out there committing
atrocities and we don't know who they
are this is Exhibit A right here
checking her phone during the moment of
silence actually it's not a moment of
silence it's eight minutes of silence
they kept this up for eight minutes
kneeling on the hard floor in honor of
George Floyd now I ask you have we ever
seen anything like this before many
great figures many icons many world
renowned people many heroes right have
have died and there's been moments of
silence for them and other symbolic
gestures to honor them have we ever seen
eight minutes kneeling on the ground to
honor anybody and this is for George
Floyd this is the
I think the most extravagant and solemn
memorial we've ever seen politicians
give to anybody and this is for George
Floyd let me just say George Floyd I
believe died unjustly and that's
terrible
a lot of people died unjustly every day
and that's terrible to his life no more
important than any of theirs they're all
important all inherently valuable as we
discussed but other than how he died
there's this was not a great man there
is no evidence that he was a great man
or even a good man so you could be upset
about the injustice of it and that's
fine it's understandable but turning
this man into a martyr and a hero and
canonizing him after his death is
ridiculous and outrageous and offensive
it is possible you know to make the case
that someone died unjustly without
falling to your knees in worship and
adulation and acting like they were
great you know heroes that should be
remembered through the ages it is
possible it's very possible so yeah we
could go with that strategy and also by
the way you can make that case without
pretending that you've been distraught
and in mourning for three weeks over
this this death because nobody believes
you anyway when you have these Democrat
Paula G's say that we're so distraught
about George Floyd oh you're not you're
not nobody believes that no one takes
that any more seriously than they take
these these these white Democrats in
African garb it's totally ridiculous and
that's why the Democrats are cancelled
all right before we wrap things up there
is something else I needed to say I
don't do this very often but I must
issue a retraction I was apparently
fact-checked on something that I said
yesterday and it turns out unknowingly I
did spread fake news you may remember I
played this video of the mayor of
Minneapolis Jacob Frye dancing while
wearing a
wife's pants now I said yesterday that
this dancing occurred at a BLM rally
over the weekend and I said that because
that's what the internet told me and the
Internet has never lied to me until now
there's a first time for everything
turns out that was not from a BLM rally
that dancing occurred in 2018 I don't
know why I don't know why was decided in
2018 that they would inflict this on the
world but they did and they being I
don't know I don't know who's
responsible but there he is dancing so I
was wrong I must retract though I should
be clear I take no responsibility I do
not apologize this was not my fault
I blame everyone else except for me and
by the way come to think of it I guess I
have to issue a second retraction
because you may remember 35 seconds ago
I said that jacob frye was wearing his
wife's pants let's take a look at those
again just so just a still shot of him
in those pants now the truth is I have
to be clear I have no specific
information proving that he was wearing
his wife's pants now the only evidence I
have are the pants themselves which to
me from my vantage point clearly appear
to be women's pants now but those could
be anyone's wife's pants all right I
don't I don't know was Jay did she jacob
frye break into someone's house and raid
the the the you know the the woman's
dresser and take the family I'm not
saying that happen I don't know what
happened I don't know I don't know what
occurred I don't know how he obtained
the pants or why or what exactly his
reason was for wearing them I can only
speculate that's all we can do in a
situation like this but I admit that
speculation on a matter as serious as
this is irresponsible and reckless all I
can say for sure let me stick to the
facts is that somehow for some reason
Jacob Frye came into possession of those
pants which have the appearance of being
women's
pants put them on and walked outside
it's all I can report with confidence
maybe he got them from the women's
section of a consignment shop who knows
we may never know and you know there are
some answers that perhaps we are better
never knowing so glad I could get that
all off my chest and I think we'll just
we'll leave it there with a little bit
of you know what a little bit of
accountability on my part this is um
this is this is a model for everybody
this is what accountability looks like
and we'll leave it there thanks I'm
ready for watching Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producer is our Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling our technical
producer is Austin Stephens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 if you prefer facts over
feelings aren't offended by the brutal
truth and you can still laugh at the
insanity filling our national news cycle
well tune into the Ben Shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more see you there